what's popping Watchers it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
this is about to be a breakdown of the
first trailer for what if season 2 that
has got me even more hyped than I
already was for this new season of crazy
chaos curated by that curious Chrome
doome U so let's just buckle up and race
on into this thing shall we all right so
Big Time spoilers coming your way
because before we get into this trailer
breakdown I'm going to read you guys the
titles for all the episodes for this
next season so that you guys can get
anide idea for what we could be seeing
in this trailer we have episode one what
if nebula joined the novacore episode
two what if Peter Quill attacked Earth's
Mightiest Heroes episode three being
what if happy Hogan Saved Christmas
episode four is what if Iron Man crashed
into The Grandmaster episode five is
what if Captain Carter fought the Hydra
stomper which is basically Captain
Carter's cap 2 Winter Soldier variant
adaptation episode 6 is what if the
Avengers assembled in 16002 which is
Marvel studios's adaptation of Marvel
1602 by Neil Gaiman episode 7 is what if
Hela found the 10 Rings which finds Hela
learning about the world of talo and
integrating with their society episode 8
is what if kahori reshaped the world
which features the introduction of a
cool ass new Native American hero with
the power of the Tesseract and finally
episode 9 is what if strange Supreme
intervened with the return of that crazy
ass doctor
strange but anyways what if Peter Quill
attacked Earth Mightiest Heroes is the
first episode that this trailer starts
off with as a quinjet holding the 1980s
version of a superhero Strike Team
consisting of a younger version of the
cre scientist marll giant man Bill
Foster King tachaka Hank Pim Ant-Man and
the Winter Soldier approaching what
appears to be the ferris wheel at Icon
Park in Orlando Florida followed shortly
after by a shot of King tchaka leaping
onto that Ferris wheel to relay Intel
back to his Strike Team about their
adolesc Target in the form of an
8-year-old Peter Jason quill who is
definitely not as Peter Jason chill as
the Star-Lord that we know and love from
the main 616 universe as this Peter
Quill has seemingly come into early
contact with his dark Celestial father
ego The Living Planet meaning that in
this universe there is a high likelihood
that yandu actually fulfilled his
business derangement with ego in 1988
and brought a young Peter Quill to Ego
shortly after ego's tumor killed
Meredith quill just like yandu had been
doing for a bunch of ego's other
children which is why yandu was kicked
out of star's ravagers in the first
place because ravagers don't deal in
kids but anyways after meeting with his
father on ego's planet it seems like
this young Peter Quill was able to tap
into that blue Celestial energy at the
heart of ego's planet and mastered how
to manipulate that blue energy quite
quickly just like Peter does in
Guardians 2 but this time with
devastating and destructive effects
however although it does ironically seem
like we are getting a a very bright
Burnes version of James gun's Star-Lord
character I don't think that this young
Peter Quill is seeking to cosem for the
sake of causing Mayhem I mean seeing as
Peter is literally wearing the same JD
canoe River rafter shirt and outfit that
he was wearing during the night of his
mother's death it is highly likely that
this Peter Quill is just an emotionally
distraught child given cosmic power at a
very young age and that he's just using
that power to grieve over the loss of
the woman that he loved the most in the
world and not only this but in the
trailer we can see him using his powers
to grab an orange raccoon from one of
those amusement park stands not only as
a nod to Peter's love for Rocket Raccoon
in the alternate 616 universe but him
hugging that stuff raccoon also shows
that Peter Quill is in deep need of
emotional affection and love following
his mother's death because God knows
that he wasn't getting any of that
from his self-centered sperm donor of a
Celestial Dome daddy ego who merely
wants to use Peter Quill to help him
with his great Cosmic EXP expansion and
with Peter having just witnessed the
death of one parent this 8-year-old boy
is probably willing to do everything and
anything to please ego even help ego
terraform planet Earth but anyways I
really like the little detail of those
light bulbs breaking every time Hank Pim
Ant-Man hopped from one to the next
because as we learned from Hank pin in
the first Ant-Man movie The Ant-Man suit
allows the wearer to retain their Mass
despite shrinking inside so all those
light bulbs shattered because of the
impact of each leap hpim then says that
he is with kids when denying backup When
approaching the young Peter Quill which
is hilariously inaccurate considering
Hank Pimp's strange relationship with
his daughter hope when we first meet him
in Ant-Man one then after the Marvel
Studios logo Pops in we get a shot of
hela's horned helmet in the darkness
being lit only by flashes of lightning
before we get a shot of Hela herself
approaching what appears to be the
defending forces of talo abling much
like they did at the arrival of both Wen
Wu and shuni in the shuni movie but that
is before we get this sick transition
from the approaching footsteps of Hela
to the footsteps of a nebula who has
joined the Novae in her universe as she
can be seen rocking the Nova cor uniform
and taking off a Nova cor helmet and
because of this it appears that she
might have been tasked to hunt and take
down the space ravager yandu udanta
during one of her novacore missions as
those footsteps appear to lead towards
yondu's unconscious body we can actually
see the moment that nebula and yondu's
battle began later on in the trailer
when nebula catches yondu's Arrow right
before that Arrow went right through her
eyeball and it looks like yandu did try
to distract her with a hologram of
himself first but my girl nebula was
simply the better of the two cyborgs in
that moment after this this Nova nebula
can be seen using a Hightech space
device to project a hologram of a
mysterious spherical structure a
structure that I think might actually be
one of the golden domes of these
Sovereign home World a map that I think
nebula may have taken off of yand do's
unconscious body in order to foil a
potential harbulary battery Heist
because as we learn in Guardians 2 those
batteries are quite valuable in the open
market and after this we get a cool
superhero shot of the Earth's Mightiest
Heroes of the 1980s consisting again of
King tachaka Howard Stark Bill Foster
and older Peggy Carter marll and Hank
Pim which is immediately followed by a
shot of tallow's great protector flying
over hela's head then we get this super
interesting shot of the Watchers home
reality of jagged multiversal mirrors
with the wall of mirrors to the left of
the frame
having been shattered with a giant hole
in it likely the same hole created by
Ultron Infinity when he broke into the
Watchers domain and discovered the
Multiverse in season 1 then we get our
look at an alternate universe sakar
where The Grandmaster appears to be
hosting a battle race with Gamora Tony
Stark and a valkyrie corg team up all
competing in a race to the death with
corg apparently making a little hamster
friend which is kind of adorable with
even the grandmas himself involving
himself in the high octane festivities
this is of course not the first time
that we have seen this universe in the
MCU as we get a brief look into that
Universe in the first season of what if
when the Watcher first approaches Gamora
for help against Ultron Infinity this
sakar episode of V if was actually
originally planned to debut last season
but Marvel Studios decided to push that
episode to this season instead then
right after this we get a shot of a
young ego before an army of ego clones
made out of the very dirt of planet
Earth start attacking Thor Bill Foster
and King tachaka black panther then we
see what appears to be a Hela dressed in
traditional Tallow Garb engaging in a
sparring match with Shang Chi's mother
Ying Lee not long after that we see aha
armored in the red dragon scale armor of
Tallow teaming up with wenwu against her
father Odin with Hela apparently using
the wind manipulating gravity powers
that she learned during those training
sessions with Ying Lee and when Hela and
Wen Wu attempt to restrain Odin with
their power Odin lets out a huge blast
of Odin Force to repel them back
backwards officially making this fight
the fight that I am most hyped to see
during this season because holy
like if these two managed to take down
Odin in this episode I can definitely
see whenw becoming the next new king of
Asgard alongside his co-ruler of a queen
Hela hell I can actually see Hela
killing Wen wo and just taking the whole
thing herself because that's just what
she does I mean hel's a bad you
can't kill her then we get an alternate
universe take of the Captain America
Thanos showdown from Avengers Infinity
War where Steve apparently triggers the
time Stone to activate by accident when
striking thanos's Infinity Gauntlet
which might just end up causing this
Steve Rogers and possibly even Thanos to
begin a Journey Through Time and
speaking of a Journey Through Time it
seems like we do get shots of what
appears to be the 1602 era universe as
we can see both Ant-Man and Steve Rogers
fencing some Asgardian knights in some
somewhat old school armor then we see
that green killing machine Gamora
seemingly yoink the grand Master's
melting stick from his assistant topaz
to attack an enemy off screen before we
get this sick shot of a rocket raccoon
with a lot more cybernetic alterations
than usual it looks like the majority of
his body with the exception of his head
and tail have been fully replaced by a
robotic battle suit equipped with a
massive laser gun with his right eye
also having been replaced with a red
glowing laser sight which is super
badass strange Supreme also makes his
return to the Multiverse narrative after
we last left him guarding Zola and
kilmonger in his collapsed home
Dimension prison and considering how
much this doctor strange VAR was
dabbling with dark and addictive magic
last season there is a high likelihood
that this man is about to be this
season's main villain somehow and
possibly even a major player on the
multiversal scale on the road to Secret
Wars but then again we do see that
kilmonger is back as well and that boy
do be having his own agenda so who ends
up being the True Villain of season 2 is
Up For Debate still because good Lord
there are a lot of possibilities on the
field but then the trailer introduces us
to a completely new character in the MCU
in the form of the Native Mohawk hero
kahor who gains tessaract type space
manipulation Powers after the tessaract
itself lands in the hudu no Shani
Confederacy before America was colonized
by foreigners and as a side effect of
the Tess's arrival a nearby lake in the
region is transformed into what Marvel
describes as a gateway to the stars with
one of those gateways appearing to
manifest at the bottom of the lake in
the trailer as kahori begins to fall to
the bottom since we did learn that the
Tesseract can be a gateway to the
Multiverse during that Captain Carter
episode of what if last season I can
definitely see why cahor seems to have a
big role to play this season as her
portals might allow her to open portals
across the Multiverse similar to how
America Chavez can and she might
actually end up being responsible for
Thanos coming through that portal and
grabbing Captain Carter Shield later on
in the trailer as she can be seen
standing right behind Carter in that
moment and speaking of Captain Carter
towards the end of the trailer we get
this shot of her reaching out to grab a
hand of a mysterious person holding
Loki's scepter being sucked into this
green tail air in reality with that
mysterious person likely being Loki
himself likely a Loki variant from the
1602 universe that appears alongside the
Silhouettes Of lady CF in Vision as
Wanda summons that massive portal of
chaos energy in the trailer and the
trailer ends with footage from the happy
Hogan Saves Christmas episode as Darcy
Lewis exits a store with a massive jar
of cherries while referencing 1997's
Conair in 1992's Under Siege while
trying to think of Die Hard to which
happy Hogan calls her John mlan in
reference to Bruce Willis's iconic
Christmas character and according to
happy it seems like Avengers tower has
been taken over on Christmas just like
in die hard so it's looking like Cappy's
got to do his own little Die Hard
himself in order to save Christmas I
mean we do see what appear to be two of
Tony's Ultron centries putting a Santa
hat on the a outside of the Avengers
Tower at one point but so maybe happy
might have to stop a building full of
Ultron Bots who knows but I for one
cannot wait to find out and of course
the final shot of the trailer is a shout
out to the iconic Avengers group shot at
the start of Age of Ultron but with the
Hulk noticeably absent but don't worry
Captain America is dressed up as a green
ELF so at least there is still some
green man representation which is very
important for an Avengers team but
anyways thank you guys for watching this
breakdown of the wh if season 2 trailer
you guys are amazing and I love you guys
so much you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter and Instagram
if you guys want to see me post some
weird but most importantly follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube YouTube
because we always got some great stuff
for you guys all the time and you don't
want to miss it but again thank you
thank you thank you for watching you
guys are amazing for giving me your time
and I will see you guys later bye